in this video we'll talk about histones
histones are highly basic proteins
enriched in lysine and Arginine histones
can be found in eukaryotic cell nucleus
histone forms the nucleosome it
interacts with the DNA to form
functional unit of the chromatin known
as the nucleosome histone has positive
charges and the DNA backbone has
negative charges due to phosphate group
and they interact with each other via
electrostatic interaction histone
structure is highly conserved there are
four basic type of histones h2a 2B H3
and H4 in all of these cases one common
theme is the histone fold which is
highly conserved across the histones and
across different species
now the difference lies in the tail
length so the n-terminal histone tail is
a site for several modifications and the
tail length is variable between
different different histones
and this is an extensive site for
different modifications like acetylation
phosphorylation methylation ubiquity
inhalation just to name a few
but question is how these modifications
take place so obviously there are some
proteins or machineries which can give
rise to these modifications and the
second thing is what is the consequence
of histone modification
now let me tell you there are several
histone modifications which can change
the accessibility of Chromatin towards
any other transcription Factor so it for
example there are enzymes like histone
acetyl transferase which can transfer
acetyl group onto the n-terminal of
histones
but the question is what is the
consequence
now
there is a phosphate backbone of DNA
which is tightly wrapped around the
histone due to the positive charge of
the lysine or Arginine group now when in
this particular region acetylation take
place
the positive charge gets masked that
means the interaction becomes weaker and
the DNA now would be Loosely wrapped
around the histone core
this would make the DNA accessible in
this particular region from a context of
transcription this makes sense because
many other proteins transcription Factor
now gain the access to the region of
this DNA
so overall accessibility can be
increased by modifications like
acetylation but acetylation is not the
only modification that takes place in
the histone there are many other
modifications
just to give you some idea that there
are these acetylation can take place in
different different residues for example
H4 lysine 8 or 16 acetylation is
associated with the start site of gene
expression
also there are many as other acetylation
such as H4 lysine 5 or 12 acetylation
marks the newly synthesized H4 so each
acetylation in different regions
has their own sense
majorly acetylated histones are
associated with euchromatin region a
region of the chromatin which is highly
active in terms of transcription whereas
deacetylated histone residues are found
in heterochromatin which is
transcriptionally silent
so acetylation of histones lead to a
specific code in the chromatin which is
read by specific barcode reader-like
molecules these barcode reader-like
molecules are basically specific
proteins which can recognize acetylated
histone so the question is who writes
the code who reads the code and how I
mean who can erase the code so the
writer of the code was basically the hat
or histone acetyl transfer is
the Eraser of this code was histone
de-acetylase and this code has a
differential meaning
now
the level of complexity in the histone
code is brought about by different type
of histone modifications so if we think
about euchromatin region there could be
different modifications like acetylation
and these acetylation can occur in
different different residues along with
acetylation you can also have
methylation in euchromatin region but
these methylations are brought the h3k4
dimethylation or h3k36 trimethylation
there are phosphorylation which can also
be associated with active euchromatin
there are specific modifications in
heterochromatic region several
methylations like h3k27 methylation
h3k9-dimethylation h3k9 trimethylations
are associated with heterochromatic so
overall there could be different
different types of modifications in the
histones and each of these histone
modifications would be read as a
combinatorial code
now there are other histone variants but
before that let me tell you that there
is one important part which is known as
Linker histone shown here in brown and
it kind of work like a clip holding the
DNA wrapped around the histone even
tighter now there are different histone
variants such as let's say histone
variant h2a z h 3.3 or heterogromatin
Associated variant like simp a or macro
h2a some histone variants like gamma h2x
is associated with double stranded DNA
break so these are having this kind of
histone variants have different meaning
now as per summary we looked at the
histones are highly conserved and they
have lysine and Arginine residues which
are site for several modifications like
acetylation phosphorylation methylation
Etc histones are found in all eukaryotes
across the species and highly conserved
the structure of histone is the
structure of histone is conserved it
contains that basic histone fold but in
terminal tilts are aside for
modifications now different histone
variants can change the chromatin
architecture thereby changing chromatin
accessibility and overall it might have
a role in changing the way of
transcription
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my Facebook page or you can see more
notes in my Instagram page the link is
provided in the description you can
support our Channel via super thanks you
can pay via paytm PayPal or UPI you can
follow our other channel nardmeric for
exclusive medical related content See
You in next video